you know i wanted to go ahead and get
the two points uh and feel like that
that would kind of put it out of reach
for them
um
and if we had gotten it we'd have been
in much better shape
uh as it turned out we didn't get it
and then with the touchdown
and the extra point they tied it up and
then we're in overtime and then we
didn't perform in overtime and they win
the game
first time i ever noticed that maneuver
was four years ago when the patriots
were hosting the seahawks and seattle
went up seven pending the extra point
late in the game and they went for two
and i'm thinking
has pete carroll lost his damn mind and
then once i thought about it wait a
minute it's the dagger if you do it late
enough in the game there's no way
they're going to score twice you go home
and yeah you still
you still look you take away the
necessity of getting getting the
two-point conversion but i think it's a
fair trade because if you
convert your two-pointer it's lights out
it's night night it's done and i think
that in that setting
on the road against a team like the
titans that the texans could not stop
all day you got to deliver the death
blow when you can i like it i get it i'm
not saying you do it all the time chris
and there's one key ingredient in this
as well the head coach explained this to
me a year or two ago
you got to feel good about your
two-point conversion play it's got to be
something you haven't used yet that you
practice well that matches up against
that defense do you feel good about the
play you would use that's part of the
analysis when you decide to go for two
in that spot i i i get you know i get
the i don't love that thought overall
thought i still don't i get it i
understand and listen you know other
times that maybe you do it yeah maybe if
i had russell wilson a quarterback and i
knew i was going against new england and
tom brady and company maybe i would
because i'd go well damn the chances of
tom going down and driving and scoring a
touchdown and them who have nine zillion
two point plays they'll probably have a
good one and screw us over and tie the
game so let's go for it i get it i do
you know i so but i just again i think
more times than not i would rely on the
fact of
you know again you're taking a little
pressure off the other football team and
then what if they want to go for two and
win the game now that you've left that
up there for them nobody ever talks
about that aspect you know and i know
that's not highly likely either but
neither was going for two but up by
seven you know a few years ago so when
that happens that's when a coach is
gonna go oh wait crap i just lost the
game because we went for two oh they
went for two to win the game and that's
what it's gonna take for then the
coaches to start to reconsider wait so
we'll see where that goes but i still
would make a team have to score two
touchdowns score a touchdown and then
score a nudge a touchdown for the
two-yard line
let me delve into the psychology of that
a little bit because if you're down one
and that team is driving and they score
the touchdown you're thinking as the
coach on the other sideline
i'm gonna have to score a touchdown and
convert the two-pointer to force
overtime when they go for it and they
fail and it's back to seven you kind of
like oh good i don't have to worry about
converting the two-pointer but yeah at
some point somebody's gonna say screw it
i'm i'm going for two
anyway and i'm gonna steal the win from
you you you left the door open that's
what's gonna make people finally
second-guess it a little but until then
i you know it's
this is the era of yes
analytics and aggressive that's why it's
a aaa it's a a as long as you follow the
analytics and as long as you in the
press conference go we were just trying
to be aggressive everybody goes ha ha
it's all good does it hey he was being
aggressive everybody i'm going to write
an article tomorrow they were aggressive
let them off the hook doesn't matter
they were aggressive they did they tried
to win the game i mean that's this is
what it's all come down to is everybody
gets off the hook with the aggressive
thing now
i think there's something deeper going
on and shireen williams and i talked
about this yesterday on pftpm which no
one was watching because it was up
against the bill's chiefs game so i'll
go ahead and repeat it here
as these organizations hire analytics
departments
smart brilliant mathematical minds who
have great influence over the football
operation the coach now has cover the
coach and it's not just the coach has
cover
i think some coaches feel like
i better do what the analytics person is
saying because the owner i'm not the one
i'm not the one eating lunch with the
owner right i'm not the one going to to
paisano's and getting the calzones and
sitting in the owner's office all day
long and and you know i'm out on the
practice field the and the owners
smitten with this 25 year old kid from
harvard business school and uh you know
and they're running these numbers and
saying this is what we need to do and if
i don't listen to them
they're going to start saying to the
owner that coach isn't listening my so i
i think it's it's almost become
self-preservation i think for some of
these coaches who feel intimidated by
the analytics department that their
owner has set up you're my you're right
about that i know that for sure i've
heard coach i mean i've had
conversations with coaches who yes they
feel like they almost have to bow down
to that part of their franchise right
now where you almost got to like oh
gotta listen to them they've got the ear
of the owner and the gm and things like
that to where it's added an extra little
dynamic to the to a lot of different
football teams you know but the thing i
will always argue is is there a formula
for
what mike vrabel might do on a gotta
have it type play at the two yard line a
guy who will call any defense and invent
defenses that we haven't seen all year
but for this game he's invented it and
has come out is there a formula for that
see that's where i just don't always
want to go like numbers numbers numbers
hey yeah it's good to go for it in
fourth and one yeah it's great to go
fourth and one is it good to go against
it in fourth and one when you know
there's four
350 pounders on the other side like the
baltimore ravens what do the analytics
say about that as to them specifically
so those are the things that i just look
at sometimes and just go there's
loopholes there that are you have to
take into account the opponent that week
and the game and how it's going that way
to where the numbers just i don't think
always tell the story
and i think eventually what you have to
do and here's the problem there aren't
enough hours in the week in advance of a
game you almost need to have analytics
sessions where you go through every
possible permutation where you may be
making decisions to go for two to go for
it on fourth down what part of the field
how much time left in the game you've
got an entire flow chart that kicks in
based upon the opponent that's the thing
because that's what i would want to say
to the atlantic the analytics people
don't tell me 48.2 percent of the time
this works because that is an
amalgamation of yeah that's a degenerate
jets defense is taken into that right
you know right right right let's every
week you tell me mr analytics expert you
tell me
how these numbers change given this
opponent given that we're playing
outdoors given that it's going to be 42
degrees and there's a 25 percent chance
of of rain i mean there's back up guards
playing i don't buy it yeah i don't buy
that you can build all of it in i don't
buy it and if and if they can build it
all in then it needs then then you know
what you know what needs to be happening
what needs to be happening is when the
coaches face the music after the game
and they say why did you do it yeah say
we had a little meeting
it was predetermined that in this
setting that's what we're going to do
the decision was made as an organization
on thursday that if we get into this
spot this is what we're going to do we
have that meeting every week and we make
the decision every week as to what we're
going to do if we're in this spot and
for this week that's the decision that
was made
that's where it needs to go if they're
going to embrace it they need to fully
embrace it and and the coach essentially
becomes a robot who is who is uh doing
whatever but yeah you know
like
it's a it's a weird balance it is and
that's the thing that at some point it
doesn't fit at some point the the
mathematics and the formulas don't fit
the feel and the flow of the game
and so
you're left with right whatever a coach
decides to do in the moment and he
either has to answer the media or he's
got to answer the owner when the owner
says we've got this analytics department
why didn't you listen to them yeah no i
i it's a very real aspect it's going to
be interesting to see where it goes i'll
be interested to see if the analytics
continue to kind of you know grow and
conform like you're talking about to
where they can be more specific like
that um there's certainly benefits to it
we both know that we're not trying to
discredit it but it just feels like i
think on a lot of sundays
you i
coach dungy i mean other friends i talk
to in football that are really damn good
coaches where they're just a little like
flummoxed for lacks of a lack of a
better word when they're watching the
game or we're talking about football and
they just like ah oh yeah the analytics
you know so there is some of that like
you know discontent with the coaching
community too where they feel like i
think analytics are becoming a little
bit overbearing in the conversation too
i think ultimately comes down to hiring
people you trust
trusting them to make decisions and the
owners can't act like fans when the
decision doesn't work out the owner has
to understand why the coach did what the
coach did and you know the problem is
the coach has another game to get ready
for the coach can't sit in the owner's
office and explain for two hours why
they did what they did that's what's
going
on
and some don't right but when but when
you complicate the decision-making
process because 30 years ago why'd you
do it because i thought it was the right
thing to do now why didn't you do this
why didn't you do this look at this
analytics look at that you're wasting
time when you're gonna be getting ready
for the next game uh well i think that's
the that's the issue coaches are having
they're having so there's some coaches
in football that i think on monday have
to go and answer questions from the
analytics part of their organization to
go why didn't you do this on this play
why didn't you run this play here all of
those type of things and yeah that's
cool but you know again i think that
goes back to your point you know if
they're gonna do that and bow down to
them and do that then they need to start
calling them out and press post game
press conferences be like hey you know
johnny who does the analytics who's you
know across the country at home doing it
but like zoom calling us in you know he
told us this is what we're supposed to
do so i'm going with him the owner hired
him and the owner told me to listen to
him they just got to start calling him
out that way it's going to happen it
just might not happen like totally
publicly like that but yeah
but that's the thing the coach the coach
ultimately will be admitting that he's
really not the coach that there's
somebody else who's pulling his strings
that that and that it's just it's
fascinating to me because
this is the kind of thinking that
transcends sport and in any organization
you have this from time to time where
the boss gets some bright idea and they
make a huge investment there's an
initiative in this that changes the way
everybody does everything and you're
like what am i supposed to do now when
this comes up but we've got this big
initiative we got to do this now you
know something that becomes a point of
emphasis in a in whatever company it is
and it creates friction and it creates
questions it creates confusion it makes
it harder at times to do your job and i
think some coaches chris based upon what
you're hearing from your friends they're
experiencing that it's harder to do
their jobs with the complications that
arise
from having to answer to the owner and
answer to the analytics department yeah
no they're feeling the pressure i think
it goes into their brains when they're
in the game thinking about all those
dynamics we just talked about and where
they go from there so uh yeah it's it's
again it's not going anywhere we can see
it's it's overtaking the sport there's a
lot of cool things about it but yeah
there's some issues too that i don't buy
into and yeah it's gonna be interesting
just to see how coaches and
organizations kind of formulate all this
together that they think it works the
best for them going forward
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports